drum playing that Farpoint here at
GameSpot yo check this out we got
Farpoint here psvr exclusive we're gonna
unbox it it's out now for $79.99 let's
check out what's in the box yeah you
need to cut it this box is not open we
need to cut it alright so look at that
far point right there sly stuff alright
Farpoint it's a it's actually a story
based VR game which is rare I suppose
and you're like tens of thousands
light-years away from Earth I bet this
place isn't even on the star chart so
you're on this planet at least where I
saw from the trailers like you're in
this planet and then you see like this
other person you're like yo what are you
doing here and you're like what are you
doing here and it's like aliens are
trying to shoot you up so you got shoot
back and it's pretty dope I think maybe
premier packaging right there for $79.99
oh let's see how do we Hey
I know y'all be talking about my teeth
man but a these chompers is strong yo
I'm calm
alright cool I got this open alright
let's put this in the box then this is
like when when my homies like box stuff
for each other where they look wrap it
in like five different boxes and I'm
trying to find out where it is oh there
we go
alright check this out game is right
here so you got the game obviously I'm
not slow enough man down Jim there it is
so here's the game right there you can
actually get the game by itself for
$49.99 but you ain't go and play it if
you don't got the PlayStation game
controller which is in this package so
let's put that aside for now let's check
out the main controller Doyle woo
gasps person let's see if this wall
holla holla
that's night ooh
instruction manual this is these are the
instruction mouths we get now like so
that's that's it there's nothing else
left in this box so you got a whole lot
of trash but this game is not so place
what we I it's a gun it's not a knife
oh so there you go this is the
PlayStation game controller this is
basically like two PS Move controllers
in one because you got the little or
actually yeah so here I don't know if
you could see it but it's got the
joystick for that artificial locomotion
in the game that's gonna make me sick
man I bought the Accu oh look nah no
promises man oh yeah this is the trigger
right here it feels a little hollow it's
a little bit lighter than anything else
I've shot in my life yeah I got the
little trackball right there precise
aiming they say well we'll see about
that man but yeah this is pretty much
all that comes in the box is this how to
charge this thing - that's why we have
this I imagine it's like USB 2.0 cuz it
doesn't come with anything else so yeah
as used be 2.0 so hopefully it's charged
already because I got time for charging
this I want to get it I want to get
shooting so there you go that's what
this package comes with game and your
gun bad alright y'all want to play this
let's play it
Oh ah Phil I feel good feeling good
feeling good
Alex my homies not doing a damn thing
I'm just like watching the entire world
flip over on its head and I'm just like
[Music]
well this this uh whoa get me out of
here oh come on oh please yeah there we
go
can't breathe oh here we go
oh all right I like oh this is really
cool it like it
hologram maps your game controller into
the gun okay now I'm moving so right
here i'm using artificial locomotion so
i'm using the stick to actually move and
that really that can if you're sensitive
to motion sickness oh boy
can't deal with this anymore oh so I can
take damage damn I didn't know they spit
flames here on this planet we walking
along I'm feeling okay usually by this
moment I would start yakking but I'm do
it I do it for y'all I do this for y'all
holo sight okay so if I move the I could
actually move the game controller near
my head and the reticle will actually
show up on the holo sight oh that's
really cool aw damn they really put some
thought into this I guess steamed buns
looks tasty oh snap eh it was good hey
do something we on this planet this
ain't your planet no more pat pat pat
pat oh hope she's all right
bad bad bad bad whoo all right
so I didn't yak but my overall
impressions are pretty good at this
product it tracks well and it feels
substantial if you like this video
please give us a thumbs up now if you
want to see me yak in a future video
playing VR please subscribe to our
channel here at GameSpot but I can't
make any promises thanks for watching